so we've gotten to the point where any
attempt to do actual journalism and hold
people in positions of power accountable
is going to be written off as an attack
by a huge portion of Americans because
that is exactly what their fearless
orange leader Donald Trump is doing
Donald Trump was asked by reporter yimmy
che Alcindor during his coronavirus
emergency declaration on Friday about
how he shut down the pandemic response
team Trump called the question nasty
claimed to have no idea what she was
talking about but but also sort of
blamed Anthony Fauci who was standing
behind him who just said I don't know
anything about it this is just
disgusting and stunning and watch Trump
say well I don't know
that's a nasty question maybe ask
Anthony foul gee I have no idea um my
first question is you said that you
don't take responsibility but you did
disband the White House pandemic office
and the officials that were working in
that office left this administration
abruptly so what responsibility do you
take to that and the officials that
worked in that office said that you that
the White House lost valuable time
because that office wasn't disbanded
what do you make a bath well I just
think it's a nasty question because what
we've done is and Tony has said numerous
times that we've saved thousands of
lives because of the quick closing and
when you say me I didn't do it
we have a group of people I could I
could ask for apps it by administration
but I could perhaps ask Tony about that
because I don't know anything about it I
mean you say you say we did that I don't
know anything about it you don't know
spending astray ssin perhaps they do
that you know people let people go he
used to be with a different newspaper
than you are now you know things like
that happen we're doing a great job
noticed Trump slipping in there will you
change jobs so like maybe the pandemic
response people also just changed jobs
nothing to see here denying it happen
but saying if it did happen maybe
Anthony foul do you know something about
it now there's something special that I
have for you today
on this back in 2018 Trump was asked why
did you cut the pandemic response team
and at the time Trump knew exactly what
he was being asked
and he didn't deny doing it and in fact
he defended what he did he said hey we
haven't used those people and I don't
want to pay people that we aren't using
remember Trump three days ago saying
pandemic response that's nasty maybe ask
voci here is Trump right after he did it
saying oh yeah I did it and here's why
some of the people we cut they haven't
been used for many many years and if we
have a need of we can get him very
quickly and rather than spending the
money and I'm a business person I don't
like having thousands of people around
when you don't need them so Friday it's
I didn't cut anyone that's a nasty
question if anybody did get cut
maybe foul he did it I don't know when
he did talk about it back in 2018 he
knew exactly what he had done he
defended doing it but the real thing
here is it wasn't Trump being a liar and
Trump being incompetent that's not new
the treatment of journalism is is what
is actually nasty here calling
journalism nasty is very very nasty
Donald Trump has framed up a situation
where as far as he's concerned he's done
everything right and Obama everything
wrong questioning him about it is nasty
asking questions like you did this and
it didn't work out well are you
responsible that's a gotcha question in
this era and of course there's always
the question is he more likely to refer
to women as nasty is he more likely to
be referring to black women as nasty as
is the case in this particular instance
I don't know we'd have to run the
numbers on that one never knows but
what's nasty is Trump's behavior his
competence which is incompetence his
treatment of others others and
absolutely and totally weaponizing
delusional narcissism weaponized
delusional narcissism maybe should be
the tagline of this administration have
you ever wanted to learn to play the
guitar but you've had trouble committing
to the time and money required to
actually take lessons I have the perfect
solution for you it's called fender play
it's an app developed by the iconic
guitar company fender it lets you learn
to play your favorite songs in minutes
on your schedule within
our active video lessons that are very
easy to follow you can use it for guitar
bass or ukulele I've been using fender
play to learn the ukulele I've gotten a
lot better than I thought I would in a
couple of months I had tried teaching
myself using some YouTube videos didn't
really get anywhere night and day
difference since I've started using
fender play and they have personalized
learning paths that will cater to your
musical tastes you can use it on your
phone tablet or computer and you learn
at your own pace which is just awesome
one year of membership gives you access
to thousands of lessons for less than
the cost of one traditional in-person
lesson and when you go to fender dot-com
slash Pakman you'll get to try it
totally free for two whole weeks free
two week trial don't lose out on that
without any commitment that's f en de
our comm slash Pakman PA que ma n fender
dot-com slash Pakman